[Applause]
you've been black in africa
yeah interesting
you've been black in america uh-huh i've
been black in europe too
black in europe what's the easiest
the easiest
i would say black and africa is the
easiest
because most of the bad [ __ ] that
happens to you isn't because you're
black
it's because of something else oh again
i'm not just talking about
racial issues i'm talking about issues
in general like if you had to choose a
place to be black in the world where
would you choose well i live here
[ __ ] like
obviously i've made that choice keep
talking to me like that it won't be that
much longer
keep talking about to make america a
little greater if you keep talking
agents are going to be right outside
do you want some ice with that water
like yes he's here no but but an
interesting an interesting experience
yeah i'm sure that there's a lot of
people in america right white black
indian asian et cetera
that we're very critical of america but
we haven't lived anywhere else in the
world right right so a lot of times we
look at the rest of the world with these
rose-colored glasses right right like
there's a lot of like white americans
right
they look at canada and europe and we're
like you see how much more progressive
they are over there
right like look how much much less
racist they are and then you go to one
soccer game and they're chucking bananas
at the black players and you're like oh
people are racist in europe europe
racism canada might not be
no can't cancel canada's got its own
[ __ ]
i guess my point i'm trying to make is
like we all if you don't travel and
experience the world you look at these
other places in the world
they're awesome and you think they're
awesome and you have this really unique
experience where you've been able to be
black in all these places yeah and i'm
curious about your perspective on
when you are trying to make
america better right right as we all are
we all want america to be better every
single day
right but you also have this i assume
and i ask
you also have this perspective where
you're like you're like yo we
this is really good too there are parts
of this that are good
sure is that does that make sense there
are absolutely parts of this that that
are great
that are like i love something about
america that
most other countries not all other
countries don't have is
america is a country that was built on
convenience a lot of [ __ ] we do
we do it the fastest quickest way
possible right that's a great point
and in europe like in france to get
a certain kind of uh like paperwork done
you've got to go through this weird ass
[ __ ] why is it that way because that's
the way we've done it since like
napoleon we tried to open a bank account
for my mom's sister in india just to
send her money right oh yeah that [ __ ]
took
three days going back back back just
like the right person wasn't there
hey nobody can open a bank account today
right crazy there are places in spain
restaurants in spain that will be closed
at lunch time
because they're taking a lunch break
yeah a nap if you will a siesta
it's like but it's lunch time yeah la
palsa like the what like
look there's a lot of [ __ ] in our
country that's not great
but like the one thing that usually tr
you know triumphs overall that is like
am i are you trying to give me money
then i will make it as easy as possible
for you to give me money whereas other
parts in the world they make it
difficult for me to give you my money
here take my money i just want to be
able to do this do you ever feel
conflicted
where there's this part of you that's
like like uh
with this part of you it's like i can't
say that
america has got some dope [ __ ] because
that almost seems like
i'm uh undermining the black struggle no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
i don't understand the question i
understand articulate the question i'm
trying to
what you're asking me is can i not
or do i feel like i can't gas up america
because if i do
it looks like you're not like i'm
selling out i'm selling now i'm
i'm like a herschel walker or something
like that right right when you have the
experience yeah potentially gas of
america because you've
experienced sure well i'm gonna tell you
like this we've i've had
on brilliant idiots i remember i told
you about like growing up in a country
where the government could just come up
and snatch you and take you away to
ghost houses and they totally lived
across the street from a ghost house
like so crazy
like i hear the people screaming at
night right
and now we see people in portland
getting snatched up
in unmarked vans and taken away and so
they're things that i see i'm like
oh this [ __ ] ain't good cause i've seen
it before
let's see where it goes the same way
that cuban people like who came to this
country
often are like oh this is how communism
starts
i have a lot of oh this is how
totalitarianism starts when you're very
you can't question the government about
anything boom
anything they do they're right it's a
government right that's interesting yeah
because you see a lot of these cubans
and people assume because they're not
white that they would be
anti-trump but these a lot of cubans are
super magical
but that's but that's it's not that
they're mega it's that they reject
or that they're racist or that they're
racist they just reject anything
that is closest to communism because
their experience will be
traumatized by the government exactly
just like you're traumatized by people
getting snatching on mark manns because
you're like oh [ __ ] this is
i've seen the worst version of this yes
and
okay but do you think that there is an
ignorance amongst americans of all races
about what the rest of the world looks
like
absolutely and if we knew that we would
have a lot more appreciation of what we
have
no i don't think so because i think if
if your premise is this is the best
country in the world
not not not best but
this is the best country in the world
right it is and and that is a
that is the truth and the reason why you
fight and you don't leave like if you
don't like it go to canada the reason
why you don't is because
no it's colder it is cold out it is
colder in canada if canada bought an
island [ __ ] if canada had to have
florida if canada bought tobago not even
trinidad just tobago
they would be they would be a force to
be reckoned with bro
no they would be a force to be reckoned
with if they just bought tobago a
force you know what it is people from
places with great weather oh
like you're 100 you need awful weather
to be like
hearty hungry and motivated
[ __ ] [ __ ] out like look at all of
europe the countries that are dragging
down europe are spain
italy greece portugal greece the
countries that are killing it
in europe are england germany
norway sweden denmark horrible weather
10 months out of the year might as well
go to work beautiful weather 10 months
out here
might as well eat a mango right a mango
isn't that what the guy what was the
pitcher uh
for the boston red sox pedro martinez
said he was getting booed
at uh is one of my favorite things that
athlete's ever said he was getting booed
at yankee stadium after giving up like a
game-winning home run
yeah and uh they're like how'd you feel
after getting booed at yankee stadium by
the entire stand after giving up a
game-winning home run he goes
oh see you don't understand like when i
was a kid i would just sit under a mango
tree
and now i'm getting booed at yankees
so he's like
you